on va changer de parti si vous le voulez
bien pour nous intéresser au modem un
certain nombre de responsables de ce
mouvement politique ont été mises en
examen dans une affaire d'emplois
présumés fictifs ce sont des
collaborateurs parlementaires au
parlement européen qui aurait travaillé
pour le parti
sylvie goulard par exemple candidate
malheureuse de la france à la commission
européenne a été mise en examen
françois bayrou le patron du parti lui
était convoqué aujourd'hui devant la
justice mais à notre connaissance il
n'est pas mise en examen de toute façon
apparemment cette perspective ne
semblait pas trop l'effrayer on lui
posait la question en début de semaine
sur bfm tv que ferait il si elle était
mise en examen eh bien écoutez tout le
monde est mis à peu près dans la vie
politique française vous reste vous
voulez qu'on fasse a listé journal sur
mise en examen question mais ils ont
vous reste mais vous resterez maire de
pause je suis à l'écouté vous voulez
quand même pas que pour une accusation
fausse j'abandonne mes concitoyens c'est
avec eux que je fais la vie alors encore
une fois on n'a pas d'information
là-dessus
la question qu'on se posait c'était est
ce que c'est une affaire politique
hervé nathan moi je voudrais vous donner
un point de vue qui est que finalement
est ce que c'est si choquant qu sacs des
collaborateurs parlementaires
travaillent pour le parti parce qu'après
tout les partis c'est d'ailleurs dans la
constitution française il y contribuer à
l'expression du suffrage et donc c'est
pas comme si il s'était occupé chez pas
moi d'aller chercher les petits enfants
de françois bayrou à l'école est ce que
c'est vraiment choquant cet cette
histoire sur le fond
j'ai fait je me pose c'est une question
qu'on peut légalement pas calmé shalit
d'accord du poilu attiyah la moralité et
puis il ya la loi et la loi elle
interdit ce genre de pratique
et quand on est garde des sceaux et ben
on est là pour faire respecter la loi
pas à transgresser surtout quand on
compte 2 garde des sceaux
potentiellement mis en examen puisque
michel mercier ancien garde des sceaux
modem trésorier du parti modem est mis
en examen
après la rupture honteuse et cumul des
mandats c'est très dangereuse
c'est bon et donc me françois méro qui
est lui aussi était garde des sceaux
dans que quinze cantons émises de la
justice on peut pas simplement balayé
d'un revers de main une jambe et tout le
monde fait ça parce que grosso modo
quand il dit tout - et mis en examen
tout le monde sait pas tout le monde
c'est la france a soumis et le front
national monte donc effectivement tous
les chiliens grande partie du sikkim
enfin au milieu il reste quand même du
monde qui n'a pas été mis en examen
voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle l' amalgame
dangereux coeur est comme ça n'arrive
pas tous les jours qu hervé nathan et
françois-xavier bellamy soit d'accord je
vous propose d'écouter tout de suite
la réaction de ce dernier a cette phrase
qu'on vient d'entendre de françois
bayrou dans la vie politique française
tout le monde est mis en examen ou à peu
près le coup dur c'est plutôt dans la
réaction de françois bayrou que j'ai
trouvée avant ça veut dire assez
incroyable comme françois bayrou 10
arbres aujourd'hui dans la vie politique
française presque tout le monde est mise
en examen c'est une manière quand même
de rompre avec ce qu'ils avaient fait le
message fort qu'il portait depuis des
années sur la nécessité effectivement de
reconstruire la confiance envers la vie
politique non dans la vie politique tout
le monde n'est pas mise en examen il ya
des centaines de milliers d'élus qui
tous les jours travaille et qui sont au
dessus de tout soupçon
alors je lui tends reprend le fil du
débat la question c'est est est ce que
cette affaire est choquant ou pas et
vous vous disiez de toute façon ce qu
ils égalent points oui parce que moi je
trouve pas ça choquant que comme vous
mais je connais la loi est la loi
laboratoire voilà parlementaires
travaillent pour le parti oui cela dit
marielle de sarnez a été le bras droit
de françois bayrou elle est mise en
examen
bien social nous demandons pardon de
détournement de fonds qui n'a d'après le
témoignage de la collaboratrice dans les
relations avec elles sont soupçonnés par
la justice d'être entré chez 10 des
égalités
on était justement plus dans la
politique et c'est le problème vient de
là il ya plusieurs affaires en fait qui
concerne le modèle et ses responsables
mais effectivement je ne sais plus
quelle était la qui sera fait sur les
emplois futurs wilks importe que ce soit
morale ou pas de toute façon ce qui
dégage on peut ouvrir le débat
2 est-ce qu'il faut une loi kylie kylie
qui considèrent comme un emploi fictif
un emploi contractée au nom du parlement
européen qui sert en fait un parti qui a
aussi une activité en france elle c'est
très précisément cette question-là au
parlement quand vous êtes embauché par
le parlement européen vous ne pouvez
travailler que pour le parlement
européen
vous avez une des lieux dans lequel dans
lesquels de faire dès que quand vous
êtes assistants parlementaires français
par exemple vous pouvez travailler
n'importe où au parlement européen c'est
pas comme ça donc est-ce qu'on remet en
question la règle pourquoi pas il me
semble que venant de la france où
justement beaucoup de responsables sont
quand même mis en examen pour ce genre
d'être délicatesse la question apparaît
très biaisée
aux yeux de nos européens pas de lévis
ça arrive en italie ce genre d'affaires
des collaborateurs carrière - non mais
pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu de
scandale mais c'est qu'il est fort
probable que si pessimiste sur la classe
politique de votre pays espère l inverse
mais bon ça c'est assez facile en tout
cas de détourner cet argent de de
bruxelles national en tout cas oui moi
je trouve que c'est assez choquant parce
que il ya quand même cette distinction
assez importante mais qui n'est pas non
plus complètement anodine c'est à dire
que la côte est a de l'argent français
du contribuable français qui est là
genre ou en tout cas les financements
qu'obtiennent les partis en france et de
l'autre tu as de l'argent à un nombre le
contribuable européen c'est à dire que
toute l'europe payent pour les
assistants parlementaires qui prêtent
leurs services à bruxelles à strasbourg
et en europe et donc c'est injuste que
cet argent passe de l'autre côté en
france pour financer des activités
nationales même si effectivement le la
frontière entre les deux est de plus en
plus floue et heureusement
après il ya une deuxième question c'est
je pense que la justice doit absolument
aller jusqu'au bout dans cette affaire
ou 6 par rapport à l'autre affaire
parallèle qui est celle toujours des
emplois fictifs et des assistants
parlementaires du prg assemblement
national marine le pen a fustigé les
juges en dix ans en se disant victime
d'une persécution politique et ou non il
faut c'est important aujourd'hui de voir
qu'il y a pas deux poids deux mesures et
que et que voilà tous les partis que ce
soit le rassemblement national ou un
parti de la majorité présidentielle qui
commet des irrégularités tous les têtes
parties sont sont poursuivis par la
justice
et s'ils sont coupables vont être
condamnées jusqu'ici la présomption
d'innocence alors nos internautes sont
assez sévères peut-être même injuste
c'est à vous d'en juger avec françois
bayrou
nicole 0,6 depuis des années bayrou joue
aux donneurs de leçons j'espère bien
qu'il sera mise en examen
rock considère que de toute façon le
modem n'est pas indispensable et que
c'est purement une affaire juridique
bayrou raconte tout et n'importe quoi
depuis des années alors peut-être qu'il
va changer de discours maintenant on
nous dit romain et citoyens payeurs
c'est une un révélateur de la politique
actuelle sans honneur ni intégrité
maxime des griefs qu'ils avaient envie
de défendre le modem peut être dans
cette affaire
j'ai envie de le défendre
parce que il ya des règles et d'ailleurs
quand on parle enfin moi j'entends la
distinction vous faites entre l'illégal
et l'immoral
le financement des partis politiques il
assure en france est d'ailleurs meilleur
distingue des assistants parlementaires
il ya une dotation pour chaque député
pour pouvoir avoir des assistants et par
ailleurs au nom au prorata du nombre de
parlementaires ya des dotations pour les
parties donc d'une certaine manière la
répartition des rôles l'aller tout cas
c'est connu et on se rappelle d'ailleurs
fait que affaire je pense notamment
celles qui ont entouré françois fillon
que on allait voir aussi ce que
faisaient les assistants parlementaires
ou ce qu'il ne faisait pas alors qu'ils
étaient pourtant il était pourtant payé
après j'entends que c'est
potentiellement beaucoup moins immoral
que d'autres choses moi ce qui
m'inquiète et je vais te voyais est
d'accord avec monsieur bel ami
c'est aussi l'attitude de françois
bayrou et on peut passer et on peut et
on peut pas se réjouir d'ailleurs que
d'une certaine manière françois bayrou
avec ce qu'il a pu incarner soient
mêlées à cette affaire la plus que
d'autres partis politiques parce que on
peut pas dire que
les tout le monde est mise en examen ça
ça n'existe pas cette banalisation
aujourd'hui qui est d'abord une insulte
à ces centaines de milliers de bêtes
d'élus bien souvent bénévoles qui font
leur boulot très correctement et c'est
en plus quand même nourrir aujourd'hui
des sentiments anti de défiance
vis-à-vis de la politique qui est qui me
semble très dangereux je vous comme rsa
vous a choqué cette phrase oui oui je
vais vous dire une chose c'est que ça me
choque parce que je m'attendais pas à ça
de lui
et deuxièmement ça me choque parce que
je commence à être très agacé on parlait
tout à l'heure
des désillusions des désenchantements
que peut créer le gouvernement actuel je
ne partageais pas puisque je n'ai pas
soutenu ce qui pouvait incarner mais il
y avait quand même dans les ressorts de
la victoire d'emmanuel macron l'idée qu'
il fallait il allait changer le système
y compris avec ce système avec ses gros
défauts qui à mon avis était d'un
résultat des courses vous parlez
d'illégalité il parle d'illégalité dit
c'est illégal mais c'est pas immoral bon
et l'histoire ferron c'est immoral mais
ce n'est pas illégal
on est d'accord donc au final de toute
façon on peut t'il en examen ils sont en
train de rompre et j'oserais même pas
regardé parce que ça viendra nourrir
tous les populismes le nombre
aujourd'hui de responsables et de cadres
de la république en marche qui ont des
problèmes avec la justice
ok et je trouve que la réponse qui est
la réponse du gouvernement et de ses
représentants elle est quand même parti
allemand faible avec ce qui était
attendu par les gens et c'est grave
parce que ça va au final pénaliser
l'ensemble des acteurs politiques donc
moi oui je suis je suis assez énervé
d'entendre françois bayrou agir de la
sorte merci beaucoup et nous allons
laisser le dernier mot à un internaute
marco qui montre que d'un point de vue
tout le monde peut en prendre pour son
grade
y compris françois fillon parce que je
pense que c'est à lui que s'adresse tout
ceci me rappelle fameusement un certain
candidat à la présidentielle mise en
examen alors qu'il affirmait n'avoir
rien fait d'illégal
et bien voilà point de vue c'est fini
pour ce soir et pour cette semaine merci
beaucoup à tous on se retrouve lundi à
la même heure et derrière le même écran
merci